This is a story of D2Hawkeye,
a medical data mining
company located in
Waltham, Massachusetts.
The company was founded by Chris
Kryder, a medical doctor who
was an MIT physician
in the 1990s.
The company was founded in 2001.
I have been in the board
of this company since 2002.
The company combines
expert knowledge
and databases with analytics
to improve quality and course
management in health care.
The company was located
in Waltham, Massachusetts.
It grew very fast and was sold
to Verisk Analytics in 2009.
The overall process that
D2Hawkeye uses is as follows.
It starts with
medical claims that
consist of diagnoses,
procedures, and drugs.
These medical claims
are then processed
via process of aggregation,
cleaning, and normalization.
This data then enters
secure databases
on which predictive
models are applied.
The output of predictive
models are specific reports
that give insight to
the various questions
that D2Hawkeye
aspires to answer.
The company tries to improve
health care case management.
Specifically, it tries to
identify high-risk patients,
work with patients to manage
treatment and associated costs,
and arrange specialist care.
Medical costs, of course,
is a serious matter
both for the patient as
well as the provider.
Being able to predict this
cost is an important problem
that interests both the patients
as well as the providers.
The overall goal of
D2Hawkeye is to improve
the quality of cost predictions.
D2Hawkeye had many
different types of clients.
The most important were
third party administrators
of medical claims.
Third party administrators
are companies
hired by the employer who manage
the claims of the employees.
Now the type of clients were
case management companies,
benefits consultants,
and health plans.
The company grew and by 2009,
it analyzed monthly millions
of people through the
analytic platform it built.
This corresponded to
thousands of employers
that were processed monthly.
To analyze the data,
the company used
what we call a
pre-analytics approach.
This was based on the human
judgment of physicians
who manually analyze patient
histories and developed
medical rules.
Of course, this
involved human judgment,
utilized a limited
set of data, it
was often costly, and
somewhat inefficient.
The key question we
analyze in this lecture
is "Can we use
analytics instead?"